ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BAKER FORGE'S BRADFORD
CABALLERO ATTENDEES DALLY DODD
TORONTO EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HERTZBERG HUESO HURTADO
JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ IN. NEWMAN
NIELSEN A SHOW OF VOGUE. PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER
WILK. MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING
BY SENATOR CORTESE AFTERWARDS
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AND WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR BATES
CENTER COURT DATE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THERE IS NO POWER
GREATER THAN A COMMUNITY
DISCOVERING WHAT IT CARES ABOUT.
S. WHAT'S POSSIBLE NOT WHAT'S
WRONG THEY KEEP ASKING. ASSUME
THAT MANY OTHERS SHARE YOUR
DREAMS. THAT WAS SAID BY
MARGARET J. WHEATLEY TURNING TO
ONE ANOTHER. LEVINE AND
MERCIFUL GOD EACH YEAR AS WE
CELEBRATE CINCO TAMAYO WE
REMEMBER THE BATTLE OF PLAYBOY.
AND ITS IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
FUTURE OF THE UNITED STATES.
TODAY WE ASK YOUR HELP AS WE
WORK TO LEADER COUNTRY FORWARD
FOR THE BENEFIT OF OUR
DESCENDANTS. MAY WE HAVE THE
COURAGE AND DETERMINATION TO
ENGAGE IN NEEDED COURAGEOUS
CONVERSATIONS. AB WORK TO FORGE
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT WILL
BENEFIT ALL ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHOSE NEEDS WE MAY NOT EASILY
NOTICE. MAY WE TRUST IN THE
GENEROSITY. IN HUMAN INGENUITY
OF EACH OTHER TO ACT ON OUR
DEEPEST DESIRES FOR GOODNESS
AND RIGHT. WE CONTINUE TO TRUST
IN THE OUTPOURING OF YOUR
SPIRIT. TO WAKE US UP TO THE
NEW AND SURPRISING
POSSIBILITIES EMERGING FROM OUR
CURRENT SITUATION. WE MAKE OUR
PER IN YOUR NAME. COMMENT.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME AND
SALUTING THE FLAG OF THE
GREATEST NATION ON THE PLANET I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE AMERICA AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS
ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. MEMBERS TODAY
WE HAVE CENTER LAMONT AND STERN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. THAT'S
WHICH I'M A GOOD MORNING.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. PARTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
THERE ARE NONE HOW. WE GO.
THERE WE GO MOTIONS THE RENTAL
RESOLUTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
PURSUANT TO JOINT RULE THIRTY
THREE POINT ONE JOINT RULE
SIXTY ONE WILL BE SUSPENDED TO
ALLOW THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE TO MEET A REPORT SB
SIX NINE SEVEN AFTER FISCAL
DEADLINE THIS REQUEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED. BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE. THE NON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. SECOND READING INSPECTOR.
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS AND SENATE BILL
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU NOW
MOVING ONTO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS CENTER LARA
LAYERED ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
GOVERNMENT GOVERNORSHIP POINTS
ENSURE. YES THANK YOU- MISTER
PRESIDENT- THIS FIRST ONE IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR
HEATHER BOLD'S IS DIRECTOR OF
THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE SAID AT CDC ARE HE'S A
LICENSED PSYCHOLOGIST SHE SPENT
OVER TWENTY YEARS WORKING IN
VARIOUS ROLES AT THE DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE AND SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON APRIL TWENTY
EIGHTH ON A FOUR ZERO VOTE WITH
ONE MEMBER ABSENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS APPOINTMENT. IN
NINETEEN NINETY MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM SO. ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS. AYE BATES. AYE
BAKER I FORGES I BRADFORD I
HAVE A YELLOW I CORTES THREE
FIVE DALLY FIVE I DODD. THE
RAZA I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH FIVE
HERTZBERG HI HUESO. HURTADO
JONES HI KAMLAGER I GLARED HI
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE FIVE MELENDEZ.
MAN FIVE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I A
CELLO VOCALS HI PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE AYE
AYE CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE WILK.
SIMILAR MOVES A CALL NOW MOVING
ON THE FILE ITEM IT. THE
PRESIDENT BERMAN FILE LATEST
THE CONFIRMATION OF SUSAN
GROUNDS OUT TO THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD SHE HAS
SERVED ON THE BOARD SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN SHE ALSO WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON APRIL TWENTY
EIGHTH ON A FOUR TO ZERO VOTE
WITH ONE MEMBER ABSENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT.
HEARING SHE NINE MEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS. AYE
BATES I BAKER. HI FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD HI KAVEH ADAM HIGH
COURT TESTING HI DALLY HI DODD.
THE RAZA I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER. I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH I HERTZBERG I
HUESO. HI HER TADO HI JONES HI
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. MAN FIVE
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I WOULD SHOW A
VOGUE I CAN I PORTANTINO I ROTH
AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER. HI AMBERG
AYE BY CASKEY I WIENER I WILK.
MMHM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD I.
MELENDEZ WILK. FIVE THIRTY SIX
NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. NOW MOVING ON
MEMBERS TO SENATE THIRD READING
OF A NUMBER OF ITEMS ARE TAKING
UP THIS MORNING WE'RE STARTING
OFF WITH FILE ITEM TWELVE
CENTER ARCHER LETTER ARE YOU
PREPARED AS HE'S BEING
PREPARING HIMSELF OUT OF
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR EIGHTY FOUR BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA AND ACTUALLY
INTO HOME INSPECTIONS. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR REGARDING LICENSE PLUMBING
CONTRACTOR REPAIR EXEMPTIONS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW PLUMBING
CONTRACTORS ARE LCENSED BY THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSING
BOARD AND ARE CERTIFIED TO
PERFORMANCE SEWER LATERAL
INSPECTIONS AND MAKE REPAIRS
BASED ON THEIR INSPECTIONS.
SEWER LATERAL INSPECTIONS ARE
NOT PART OF A TRADITIONAL HOME
INSPECTIONS SEWER LATERAL
INSPECTIONS WHICH ARE INTENDED
TO IDENTIFY SURE LEAKS ARE
REQUIRED BY MANY CITIES AND
COUNTIES AT THE SAME TIME HOME
IS SOLD. EXISTING LAW PROHIBITS
A HOME INSPECTOR A HOME
INSPECTION COMPANY OR EMPLOYEE
OF THE HOME INSPECTION COMPANY
FROM PERFORMING WORK ON ANY
HOME WHICH THEY HAVE INSPECTED
IN THE PAST TWELVE MONTHS.
THESE PREVENT THE PROHIBITIONS
ARE IN LAW BECAUSE HOME
INSPECTORS ARE NOT LICENSE
HOWEVER PLUMBER'S LICENSE BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LICENSING
BOARDS ARE ALLOWED TO INSPECT
AND REPAIR SEWER LATERALS.
CURRENTLY IT IS CONSIDERED
UNFAIR BUSINESS PRACTICE FOR
PLUMBING CONTRACTOR TO DO BOTH
THE SEWER INSPECTION AND THE
SEWER REPAIR IF THE COMPANY IS
ALSO COMPACT THAT CONDUCTED A
HOME INSPECTION. ON THE SAME
PROPERTY. SENATE BILL FORTY
FOUR CORRECTS THIS POBLEM
ALLOWS THE CONSUMER MORE
CHOICES AND ALLOWS THEM TO SAVE
TIME AND MONEY. SENATE BILL
FORTY FOUR CLARIFIES THAT THE
LICENSE PLUMBING CONTRACTOR CAN
MAKE REPAIRS TO A SEWER LATERAL
PIPE. THEY HAVE INSPECTED EVEN
IF THEY OR THEIR COMPANY HAS
PERFORMED A HOME INSPECTION ON
THE SAME PROPERTY. AND IT
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN PROVIDED
AN EXEMPTION FOR LICENSE ROOF
INSPECTORS SENATE BILL FORTY
FOUR WOULD PROVIDE A SIMILAR
EXEMPTION FOR THESE SPECIALIST
LICENSED PLUMBERS. SENATE BILL
FORTY FOUR PROTECT CONSUMERS
WHILE ALLOWING THEM TO CHOOSE A
LICENSED PLUMBING CONTRACTOR TO
CONDUCT A SEWER LATERAL
INSPECTION AND MAKE ANY NEEDED
REPAIRS. EVEN IF THE PLUMBERS
COMPANY HAS PERFORMED A HOME
INSPECTION ON THE SAME PROPERTY
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FILE ITEM. TWELVE O. K. MMHM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM TWELVE. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES I
BAKER FIVE FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
COURTESY I DALLY. OUR AYE DODD.
FIVE DURAZO AYE EGGMAN I GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG BY FIVE HUESO HI HER
TADO I JONES HI KAMLAGER HI
LAYERED. I LEYVA I MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ. MAN I NEWMAN. NO
NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN.
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO. HI
SKINNER. HI NUMBER I LIKE
CASKEY I WIENER AYE WILK I.
MMHM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN FIVE
MELENDEZ PAN. FIVE THIRTY FIVE
KNOWS ONE THE MEASURES PASSED
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN SENATOR PAN ARE YOU
PREPARED SEEN IN THE IDEAS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR PAN AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE HERE PEN
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATORS
SB THREE TWENTY SIX WOULD ALLOW
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT TO STAND IN CALIFORNIA
EVEN IF THE ACA IS REPEALED BY
THE SUPREME COURT. AND I'M
TALKING ABOUT PROTECTIONS
AGAINST PRE EXISTING CONDITIONS
EXCLUSIONS. REQUIREMENT THE
PLANTS HAVE TO SELL YOU A
POLICY REGARDLESS OF YOUR
HEALTH STATUS AND RENEW THE
POLICY NO MATTER WHAT KIND OF
ILLNESS YOU MAY HAVE BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH. RESTRICTIONS ON
PLANS TO INCREASING PREMIUMS WE
GET SICK. AND ENSURING THAT
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS ARE
COVERED BY HEALTH PLANS. UNDER
EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAW TODAY
IF THE ACA'S. REPEALED SO WITH
THESE IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS WHICH WOULD MEAN
THAT IF YOU'RE COVERED YOU GOT
SICK AT THE WHEN YOU AT RENEW
YOUR- RATES GO. SKY HIGH
ARTICLE JUST SIMPLY REFUSE TO
RENEW YOU WHILE YOU WERE ILL.
UNFORTUNATELY THE ACA IS AGAIN
BEFORE THE SUPREME COURT WE
HOPE THE OUTCOME WILL BE
POSITIVE CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN IMPLEMENTING
THESE INSURANCE MARKET REFORMS
AND THERE'S NO REASON TO TIE
OUR LAW IN THISWAY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB THREE TWENTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN. SKINNER- TROUBLE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL THREE TWENTY SIX IF
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT THIS
PLEDGES LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO
DO THIS YEAR OTHER THAN A
DRESSING THE PANDEMIC IT SHOULD
BE TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS WITH
PRE EXISTING CONDITIONS AND
ENSURE THAT THEY CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THE CARE THEY NEED TO
LIVE. THIS LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
STEP UP TO THE PLATE AND HELP
OUR MOST VULNERABLE TO MAINTAIN
THE COVERAGE THAT THEY NEED
WHEN THEY ARE IN LIFE
THREATENING. SITUATIONS THIS
MAY LOOK LIKE A SMALL BELL AND
A SIMPLE FIX RELATIVE TO SOME
OTHER ISSUES IN HEALTH CARE.
BUT FOR THOSE WITH PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS OR THOSE WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS WITH PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS. THIS IS MONUMENTAL.
ON BEHALF OF THOSE WITH CANCER
THAT HAVE DENIED COVERAGE.
THOSE WITH DIABETES WERE
STRUGGLING TO RECEIVE THE
MEDICINE THEY NEED THOSE WITH
HIV THAT ARE WERE DENIED
HEALTHCARE AND ALL OTHERS WHO
HAVE TO WORRY WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO LIFE SUSTAINING
MEDICAL CARE. I RESPECTFULLY
COMPASSIONATELY ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. TURNING SHE NINE MONTHS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. ATKINS FIVE
BATES FIVE BAKER. I PORCHES
FIVE BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
CORTESE HI DALLY. DODD FIVE TO
RAZA I EGGMAN I GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ. GROWTH HI HERTZBERG
FIVE WITH SO. HI HER TADO I
JONES FIVE KAMLAGER I LAYERED
HI LEYVA. I MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ.
MAN FIVE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I
HOPE CHAU VOGUE AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. HI RUBIO I
SKINNER HI I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT
I LIKE HOUSEKI. FIVE WIENER AYE
WILK HI. I'M SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA I. DALLY. GONZALEZ HI
MELENDEZ. FIVE THIRTY SIX NOS
ZERO THE MEASURES PASSED NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
CENTER LEYVA WHO PREPARED YES
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL FOR FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND ACTUALLY DID
TO HEALTHCARE COVERAGE. CENTER
LEVEL GOOD MORNING MR PRESIDENT
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS SB FOUR
FIFTY FIVE WOULD EXTEND COVERED
CALIFORNIA'S EMERGENCY RULE
MAKING AUTHORITY FOR ITS
REGULATORY PACKAGES UNTIL
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN. THIS BILL FOLLOWS UP ON
MY PREVIOUS LEGISLATION SB
TWELVE FORTY FIVE FROM TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE EXTENT
COVERED CALIFORNIA'S EMERGENCY
RULEMAKING UNTIL JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. KNOWING ITS
RULE MAKING AUTHORITY IS SET TO
EXPIRE SOON AS WELL AS THE EVER
EVOLVING LANDSCAPE AND HEALTH
CARE COVERED CALIFORNIA NEEDS
THE FLEXIBILITY TO CREATE AND
IMPLEMENT REGULATIONS QUICKER
THAN THROUGH THE PERMANENT
RULEMAKING PROCESS. WITHOUT
THIS EMERGENCY RULE MAKING
AUTHORITY COVERED CALIFORNIA
REGULATIONS COULD CONFLICT WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL POLICIES AND
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO A LACK OF
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HEALTH
CARE FOR CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
THE COVER CALIFORNIA CAN
CONTINUE TO PROMPTLY RESPOND TO
ITS CHANGES AT THE FEDERAL AND
STATE LEVELS SB FOUR FIFTY FIVE
WOULD ALLOW ITS EMERGENCY
RULEMAKING AUTHORITY TO SPEAK
SAID UNTIL JANUARY ONE OF
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN MEMBERS
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION IT
GIVES COVERED CALIFORNIA THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT THEY NEED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. IN
NINETEEN NINETY. THIS MEASURE
IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU KNOWLEDGE
WITH WITH OUR FULL HOUSE OKAY
MA'AM CENTER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BECKER AYE
BORJAS I BRADFORD HI CABALLERO.
CORTESE. FIVE DALLY THOSE. DODD.
FIVE TO RAZA HI EGGMAN I GLAZER.
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG FIVE WESA. HI HER
TADO HI JONES HI KAMLAGER HI
LAYARD HI LEYVA. I MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ. MAN I NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN I A CHIRLA I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH FIVE RUBIO I
SKINNER. I UMBERG HI MY CASKEY
AYE WIENER AYE WILK. HI
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CABALLERO I
DALLY. MELENDEZ. MARCH THIRTY
SIX NOS ZERO THE MEASURE
PROCESS NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN
SENATOR CAFIERO ARE YOU
PREPARED. WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY. MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY SENATOR ALAN
ARE YOU PREPARED. YES MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FIVE NINETY BY SENATOR
ALAN AND ACTUALLY INTO
ELECTIONS. MEMBERS THIS BILL
EXTENDS ANY TERM OF OFFICE
THAT'S SET TO EXPIRE IN MARCH
OR APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
UNTIL AFTER THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO STATEWIDE PRIMARY ELECTION
IN THE MINISTRATION THE OATH OF
OFFICE TO THE NEWLY ELECTED
OFFICEHOLDER. MEMBERS AS YOU
RECALL WE MOVED THE FIRST WE
CONSOLIDATED ELECTIONS AND THEN
OF COURSE WE MOVED THE PRIMARY
AND A NUMBER OF CITIES WHO HAD
THEIR ELECTIONS NOW SET FOR THE
PRIMARY ELECTIONS THE CITY
COUNCIL ELECTIONS- SET UP RULES
WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT ARE
THE PRIMARY WOULD BE IN MARCH
OR APRIL AS IT WAS. UNTIL WE
MOVED IT TO JUNE BECAUSE OF THE
CENSUS DELAYS SO THIS JUST
ALLOWS THOSE THOSE COUNCIL
MEMBERS TO SERVE A FEW EXTRA
MONTHS UNTIL THE CITY CAN THEN
HAVE THEIR PROPER ELECTION AT
THE PRIMARY THAT WILL BE
PRESUMABLY HOLDING IN JUNE IT'S
GOT NO OPPOSITION- YOU PASS OUT
OF POLICY COMMITTEE WITH.
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I RESPECT FASHION OF A- ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. TURNING. TO SENATOR
LEVEL. NO OUR IN NINETEEN MA'AM
SECTOR PLEASE CULTURAL. ALLEN
AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES I BAKER. HI FORGES HI
BRADFORD AYE CABRERA AYE
CORTESE AYE DALLY. FIVE DODD HI
DURAZO HI EGGMAN BY GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. FIVE
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. I HER
TADO FIVE JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ MAN FIVE NEWMAN
AYE NIELSEN. I A TELEVOTE AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. HI I'M
BURKE RIGHT I LIKE ASKING AYE
WIENER AYE WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING
BACK TO FILE ITEMS EIGHTEEN
SENATOR KIRBY ARE YOU PREPARED
SHIA'S MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR CABALLERO AND
ACTUALLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CENTER COPIER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB THREE
TWENTY THREE WHICH WOULD CREATE
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS. FOR
CLAIMS AGAINST WATER AND SEWER
AGENCY RATE SETTINGS. WATER AND
SEWER UTILITY BUDGETS ARE
FUNDED BY REVENUE COLLECTED
THROUGH SERVICE RATES THESE
RATES PROVIDE THE FUNDING
NECESSARY TO SUPPLY SAFE
DRINKING WATER UPGRADE AND
IMPROVE AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND TO OPERATE EFFECTIVELY.
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS LAWSUITS
THAT SEEK REFUNDS OR SEEK TO
INVALIDATE EXISTING RATE
STRUCTURES YEARS AFTER RATES
HAVE BEEN ADOPTED AND COLLECTED
DELAYED LAWSUITS CAN THREATEN
AN AGENCY'S ABILITY TO REPAY
DEBT GUARANTEED. BY REVENUE
FROM RATE DERAIL ONGOING
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AND
GENERALLY UNDERMINE AND
AGENCIES ABILITY TO MAINTAIN
STABLE BUDGETS NECESSARY TO
OPERATE EFFECTIVELY. SB THREE
TWENTY THREE ADDS CONSISTENCY
TO EXISTING LAW BY AUTHORIZING
A LITTLE LOCAL AGENCY OR
INTERESTED PERSON TO BRING A
VALIDATION ACTION IN SUPERIOR
COURT TO DETERMINE THE VALIDITY
OF A FEE OR CHARGE FOR WATER
AND SEWER SERVICES IF A
VALIDATION ACTION IS NOT
BROUGHT WITHIN A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS PARTIES WOULD BE
BARRED FROM CHALLENGING THE
VALIDITY OF THE FEE FOR THE
CHARGE. THIS BILL IS IN LINE
WITH EXISTING PRECEDENT MODELED
AFTER THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DAY STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
ENACTED IN TWO THOUSAND PER
MUNICIPAL ELECTRIC RATES OR
CHARGES BY ALLOWING CUSTOMERS
TO BRING CHALLENGES WITHIN A
REASONABLE BUT LIMITED PERIOD
OF TIME THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
BALANCE THE INTEREST OF RATE
PAYERS WITH THOSE A PUBLIC
WATER AND SEWER AGENCY AND IN
THE CURRENT PRACTICE. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEN NONE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I BATES NO
BAKER. I FORTUS. BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO AYE CORTESE HI DALLY.
DODD HI THERE ASA I EGGMAN I
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. I FURTADO
HI JONES I KAMLAGER. HI WHERE'D
HI LEYVA I MCGUIRE. HI MELENDEZ.
MAN I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I A
SHOW OF BOTH. HI PAM I
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH FIVE RUBIO.
HI SKINNER HI I'M BURKE HI LIKE
HOW SKI HI WIENER. FIVE WILK. I
HOME SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR JUST. DALLI
HI I GROVE. MELENDEZ. FIVE
THIRTY FOUR KNOWS ONE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS REMOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE SOONER
OR LATER HE'S PREPARED BROWN
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL TWO FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
LAYERED AND ACTUALLY DIDN'T
AGING. THRILLER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SB TWO FIFTY EIGHT
WILL UPDATE CALIFORNIA'S VERY
DATED DEFINITION OF GREATEST
SOCIAL NEED IN THE PROGRAMS OF
THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT
AMERICANS ACT TO INCLUDE
CULTURAL OR SOCIAL ISOLATION
CAUSED BY HIV STATUS. A B. FOR
THE DRUG COCKTAIL FOR HIV I RAN
AN AIDS SERVICE AGENCY FOR
THREE YEARS AND IT WAS OUR
DREAM FOR PEOPLE TO LIVE TO OLD
AGE BUT AT THAT POINT IT WAS
JUST A DREAM. NOW AS OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN MORE THAN 50% OF
PEOPLE. LIVING WITH HIV IN
CALIFORNIA ARE FIFTY YEARS OR
OLDER. AND BY EASING THE BURDEN
OF CONNECTING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS TO
SUPPORTING AGING AGING SERVICES
OLDER ADULTS AGE IN PLACE WITH
DIGNITY SENATE BILL TWO FIFTY
EIGHT IS A LEGISLATIVE LGBT
CAUCUS PRIORITY AND IS CO
AUTHORED BY EVERY MEMBER OF THE
CAUCUS IT IS ALSO SUPPORTED BY
MANY AREA AGENCIES ON AGING AND
LGBT ORGANIATIONS- MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
WHERE. I THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FIFTY AND I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FROM SANTA CRUZ- FOR
AUTHORING- THIS BILL I
REPRESENT A HUGE COMMUNITY OF
LONG TERM HIV. SURVIVORS AND
THAT IS THAT IS. IN MANY WAYS A
TERRIFIC THING BECAUSE THERE
WAS A TIME WHEN WE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY LONG TERM SURVIVORS BECAUSE
SO MANY WERE DYING ON SO MANY-
PEOPLE LIVING WOULD HAVE BEEN
LIVING WITH HIV NOW FOR
DECADES- AND- THE
PHARMACEUTICAL ADVANCES HAVE
AND THEY ARE- YOU KNOW GREAT
CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY BUT MANY OF THEM ARE
STRUGGLING FOR A LOT OF
DIFFERENT REASONS HAVING LOST
THEIR ENTIRE SOCIAL NETWORKS-
DEALING WITH- MENTAL HEALTH AND
SOMETIMES SUBSTANCE USE. I
CHALLENGES- ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES- AND SO I AND HEALTH
CHALLENGES BECAUSE FOR MANY
BEFORE THE MEDICATION CAME
AROUND I HIV WAS RAVAGING THEIR
BODY OFF FOR YEARS- AND SO WE
NEED TO BE THOSE TO SUPPORT ON
THIS IS A LONG OVERDUE CHANGE
AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU ANY FOR THE
DESCRIPTION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
ERNESTINA ANSWER EARLIER WE
TALKED CALL I RESPECTFULLY FOR
YOUR I. PHONE THANK YOU MA'AM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BAKER FIVE PORGES OR
HI BRADFORD HI CABRERA CABRERA
HI CORTESE HI DALLY HI DODD. HI
THE RAZA FIVE EGGMAN I GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE.
HERTZBERG HI HUESO. HI HER TADO
HI JONES. KAMLAGER. I LAYERED I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ.
MAN HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. A
SHOW VOGUE. HI PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI NUMBER I BY CASKEY
FIVE WIENER AYE WILK. HI I'M
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES HI GROWTH HI.
JONES. MELENDEZ NIELSEN HI.
FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE POCESS MEMBERS
REMOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
TWENTY TWO CENTER LIVE ARE YOU
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. IT LEYVA AND ACTUALLY IN
THE CIVIL ACTIONS SOONER OR
LATER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS SENATE
BILL THREE THREE ONE ALSO KNOWN
AS THE SILENCE NO MORE ACT
EXPANDS THE PROHIBITION ON
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS ALSO
KNOWN AS NDA'S. TO NOW COVER
SETTLEMENTS AGREEMENTS
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS INVOLVING
ALL FORMS OF HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION. THIS BILL ALSO
EXPANDS THE PROHIBITION ON
OVERLY BROAD CONFIDENTIALITY
AND NON DISPARAGEMENT CLAUSES
IN EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENTS TO
COVER WORKERS WHO ARE REQUIRED
TO SIGN THESE TYPES OF CLAUSES
AS PART OF A SEVERANCE
AGREEMENTS. RECENT AMENDMENTS
MAKE CLEAR THAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT PREVENT AN EMPLOYER FROM
INCLUDING A RELEASE OF CLAIMS
IN A SEVERANCE AGREEMENT IT
DOES NOT PREVENT AN EMPLOYER
FROM PROHIBITING THE DISCLOSURE
OF ANY AMOUNT PAID IN A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. IT ALSO
DOES NOT PREVENT AN EMPLOYER
FROM PROHIBITING THE DISCLOSURE
OF TRADE SECRETS PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION OR CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION THAT DOES NOT
INVOLVE UNLAWFUL ACTS IN THE
WORKPLACE. AS MANY OF YOU MAY
REMEMBER I AUTHORED AND THEN
GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED IN SB
EIGHT TWENTY ALSO KNOWN AS A
STAND ACT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. SB EIGHT TWENTY
SPECIFICALLY BANNED
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS IN
CASES OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND SEXUAL
DISCRIMINATION. IMPORTANTLY THE
STANDARD ALSO ALLOWS THE
CLAIMANT TO REQUEST
CONFIDENTIAL CONFIDENTIALITY IF
THEY SO CHOOSE. AUSTIN THIS
HISTORIC LAW THE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZE THAT SECRET
SETTLEMENTS OR HELPING TO
PERPETRATE HOSTILE WORK
ENVIRONMENTS BY ALLOWING
COMPLAINTS TO BE SWEPT UNDER
THE RUG. OF COURSE SECRET
SETTLEMENTS PLAY AS MUCH A ROLE
IN PERPETRATING WORKPLACE
DISCRIMINATION HARASSMENT AND
BIAS BASED ON RACE ETHNICITY
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AGE
DISABILITY RELIGION AMONG
OTHERS. BECAUSE HERE TO
COMPLAINTS ARE KEPT SECRET AND
THOSE WHO RAISE THE COMPLAINTS
ARE EFFECTIVELY SILENCED.
MEMBERS WE ALL KNOW IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE FOR ANY EMPLOYER
TO TRY TO SILENCE A WORKER
BECAUSE HERE SHE WAS A VICTIM
OF ANY TYPE OF HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION. THE SILENCE NO
MORE ACT WILL EMPOWER SURVIVORS
TO SPEAK OUT IF THEY SO WISH SO
THE PERPETRATORS CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND WE CAN
HOPEFULLY PREVENT ABUSERS FROM
CONTINUING TO TORMENT AND ABUSE
OTHER WORKERS. WORKERS SHOULD
ALWAYS BE ABLE TO SPEAK OUT
AGAINST THIS DEPLORABLE
BEHAVIOR IN THE WORKPLACE BOTH
THE DEMAND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TO PREVENT FUTURE ABUSERS BY
PERPETRATORS ABUSES BY
PERPETRATORS. TO HELP FINALLY
PUT AN END TO THIS CULTURE OF
SECRECY I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
VOTE BY ON SB THREE THREE ONE.
THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO.
PORTANTINO MICROPHONES BACK
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI I. ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. NO BACKER.
FIVE FOUR JUST NO BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM AYE CORTESE AYE
DALY NO NO DODD. I TO RAZA HI
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO
HI HER TADO HI JONES NO
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. MAN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO A CHOKE NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI I'M BURKE
HI LAKE COUNTY HI WIENER. HI
WILK NO. ZURCHER NO HIGHS
TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE
CENTER PANNIER PAYER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR PAN RELATIVE
TO CYSTIC FIBROSIS AWARENESS
MONTH. SENATOR PAN THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SANDERS
I STAND BEFORE YOU PERCENT SCR
THIRTY EIGHT WHICH WERE CLAIMS
MADE TWENTY TWENTY ONE A CYSTIC
FIBROSIS AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA SIX IF I PRESS IS
CURRENTLY AFFECTS NEARLY TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED CHILDREN
AND ADULTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN ADDITION MORE THAN A
THOUSAND NEW CASES ARE
DIAGNOSED PRIMARILY THROUGH
NEWBORN SCREENING EVERY YEAR.
SINCE THE FIBROSIS THE MOST
COMMON DEADLY GENETIC DISEASE-
THAT CURRENTLY HAS NO CURE- THE
DISEASE IS ACTUALLY CAUSED BY A
CHANGE IN THE CITY FIBROSIS
TRANSMEMBRANE REGULATION GENE
AND MORE THAN EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
MUTATIONS OF THIS GENE HAVE
BEEN FOUND IN CYSTIC FIBROSIS
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
ESTIMATES THAT MORE THAN TWELVE
MILLION PEOPLE ARE SYMPTOMS
CARRIERS OF THE CYSTIC FIBROSIS
GENE. DUE TO HEALTH DISPARITIES
IN NEWBORN SCREENING PANELS
THAT FILL THE CAPTURED THE RARE
MUTATIONS MANY INDIVIDUALS A
CYSTIC FIBROSIS ARE DIAGNOSED
OR MISDIAGNOSED LATER IN LIFE
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASING THE
RISK FOR FAMILIES TO PASSAGE
ANNOUNCER CHILDREN THANKFULLY
THE CYSTIC FIBROSIS RESEARCH
INSTITUTE PROUD SPONSORS OF THE
RESOLUTION HAVE DEDICATED THEIR
TIME AND RESOURCES TO FINDING A
CURE THROUGH EXTENSIVE RESEARCH
EDUCATION ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT
DEFINITELY THE CYSTIC FIBROSIS
RESEARCH INSTITUTE PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR INNOVATIVE RESEARCH
THAT SUPPORTS MEDICAL
BREAKTHROUGHS IN THERAPY.
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES IMPACTED
BY CYSTIC FIBROSIS BEGINS WITH
RAISING AWARENESS AND SUPPORT
FOR ACCESS TO TREATMENT- PLEASE
JOIN ME DECLARING MAY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CYSTIC. FIBROSIS
AWARENESS MONTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DIFFERENT SPEAK
FURTHER THIS AND DEBATE ON THE
SIDE. AND SHE NINE MONTHS
PLEASE CALL OR. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BAKER I
FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD HI
CABRERO HI CORTESE HI DOLLY
PARTON HI DODD. I TORONTO HI
EGGMAN HI GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. I HERTZBERG I WAS SO.
HI FURTADO HI JONES HI KAMLAGER
I LAYERED I LEYVA I MCGUIRE.
FIVE MELENDEZ MAN HI NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN. HI A SHOW VOGUE HI PAN
AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER. FIVE AMBERG HI LIKE
A SKI HI WIENER AYE WILK HI.
ALL EYES THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR CENTER NEWMAN ARE
YOU PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. SENATE BILL FOR
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR NEWMAN AN
ACT RELATING TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS- NEWMAN THAT DAVIS
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB FOUR FOUR
TWO WILL ENSURE THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- ABLE TO SMOOTHLY
MAKE THE TRANSITION FROM AT
LARGE ELECTIONS. TO DISTRICT
BASED ELECTIONS WITHOUT
INCURRING UNNECESSARY DELAYS AS
WELL AS THE POSSIBLE COST OF
THE CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS
ACT LAWSUIT DURING THIS
PROCESS. SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
THE CVR IN TWO THOUSAND ONE TO
PROMOTE GREATER REPRESENTATION
AND EQUITY IN ELECTIONS MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED OF
CALIFORNIA'S MORE THAN ONE
THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
SWITCHED FROM AT LARGE
ELECTIONS. TO DISTRICT BASED
ELECTIONS IN RECENT YEARS IT IS
BEENTHE CONSISTENT POLICY OF
THIS LEGISLATURE TO ENCOURAGE
POLITICAL SUBDIVISIONS TO ADOPT
DISTRICT BASED ELECTIONS WHILE
ENTERING TO SIMPLIFY THE
PROCESS FOR DOING SO. TOWARD
THAT END SECTION FIVE ZERO ONE
NINE OF CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
CODE CURRENTLY ALLOWS COUNTY
COMMITTEES WHO OVERSEE THE
ORGANIZATIONS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO ESTABLISH TRUSTEE ELECTIONS
IN A PROMPT AND INCLUSIVE
PROCESS UNFORTUNATELY HOWEVER.
AS A RESULT OF AN ACCIDENT
SINCE THE STATE LAW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GOVERNED BY A BOARD
OF EDUCATION WHICH IS PROVIDED
FOR AS PART OF THE CHARTER OF
THE CITY OR COUNTY ARE NOT
ENTITLED TO THE SAME PROCESS.
AND ARE INSTEAD CURRENTLY
REQUIRED PUT ANY HONEST I WAS
INTERESTED YEAR ELECTIONS TO
THE ELECTORS OF THEIR DISTRICT
THIS REDUNDANT AND BURDENSOME
REQUIREMENT OFTEN RESULTS IN
THE NEED TO HOLD IT TO PAY FOR
AN OFFICIAL ACTION AND
SOMETIMES EVEN. A SPECIAL
ELECTION SB FOUR FOUR TWO FIXES
THIS PROBLEM BY ENABLING
ORDINANCES APPROVING A PROPOSAL
TO ESTABLISH TRUSTEE AREAS
WHICH WILL TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY UPON ADOPTION
WITHOUT THE NEED FOR AN
ADDITIONAL ELECTION TO AFFIRM
APPROVAL. THIS IS A
DELIBERATELY NARROW BILL
DESIGNED TO STANDARDIZE AND
STREAMLINE PROCESSES ACROSS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE EITHER INCREASES THE
CHANCES OF A DISTRICT CHANGING
THE BASIS OF ITS SYSTEM OF
ELECTIONS NOR WILL IT HAVE ANY
IMPACT ON HOW THE LINES FOR
TRUSTEE AREAS. ARE DRAWN THIS
BILL RECEIVE NO NO VOTES INTO
COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSS ORDER. ON FILE
I TWENTY FOUR. IN CHINO BAY
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. FIVE ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES. BAKER. I
FORTUS. BRADFORD HI CABALLERO
HI CORTESE HI DALLY. DODD FIVE
TERRAZZA HI EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG HI HUESO. HI HER TADO
I JONES HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ MAN
I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN I A SHOW A
VOTE I PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI
I'M BURKE I LIKE ASKING. FIVE
WIENER AYE WILK I. M. SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES PORGES. DALLY MELENDEZ.
FIVE THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVES MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX
SENATOR JONES ARE YOU PREPARED
HE IS BENHAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FOUR FOURTEEN
BY SENATOR JONES AN ACT
RELATING TO LAND- JONES FOR
GEORGE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
SENATE BILL FOUR FOURTEEN
UPDATE SEVERAL PROVISIONS OF
CODE GOVERNING LAND SURVEYORS
WE'VE TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE BOARD'S CONCERNS IN
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DESCRIPTION OF IT ON THE SIDE
OF. HEARING CHAIN NINE MEMBERS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
ABUSING A YOU KNOW IT'S ROLL
CALL ON FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX.
HE'S THERE IS. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES.
I BAKER I PORCHES I BRADFORD I
HAVE A AYE CORTESE AYE DOLLY
AYE DODD HI DURAZO HI EGGMAN
AYE GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ FIVE
GROWTH HI HERTZBERG AYE HUESO
HI HER TADO I JONES I KAMLAGER
I LAYERED. I LEYVA HI MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ MAN I NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN I ACCIONES VOTE I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH FIVE
RUBIO. HI SKINNER BY AMBERG I
LIKE HOUSEKI. I WIENER. HI WILK
HI. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE
SOONER JONES YOU PREPARE FOR
THAT I DON'T HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR JONES AND ACTUALLY DID
TO HEALING ARTS CENTER JONES A
FLOOR GEORGE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY FOUR UPDATES THE DENTAL
HYGIENE PRACTICE ACT AND IS CO
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL HYGIENISTS ASSOCIATION.
AND THE DENTAL HYGIENE BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE ENSURING NINE.
MEMBERS THIS TOO IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE. NINETEEN NO
OBJECTIONS AUGUST THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
CINNABAR THE ANNOUNCEMENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT OP
OF WONDERFUL WEEKEND THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE HERE IN
THE SENATE CHAMBERS AT TEN
FORTY. THE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE
AN SENATE CHAMBERS AT TEN
FORTY. NOW SENATOR EGGMAN. WE
HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT. WELL THE
SUB THROUGH WILL START AT
BRIGHT AFTER SESSION IN ROOM.
TWENTY THREE OF. TWENTY THREE
OH TWO. NO THIRTY ONE NINE ONE-
OKAY S. BUT SUB THREE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES WILL BEGIN
AFTER SESSION IN ROOM. THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. SENATE SUB
THREE WILL CONVENE IMMEDIATELY
AFTER SESSION IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE AT NINETY ONE WE BELIEVE.
ALL RIGHT MOVING ON SENATOR
RAZA. YES MISTER CHAIR BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE FIVE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY WILL- MADE AND TEN
MINUTES IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. RIGHT SENATE SUBFOSSILS.
THIS BUDGET SO FIVE I SHOULD
SAY WILL BE MEETING IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OLD THREE TEN MINUTES
AFTER GERMAN OF SESSION.
WELCOME MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING
ON TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
THIS SHOULD BE A TIME FOR A
JOURNEY MEMORIES DO WE HAVE
JOURNAL MEMORIES. SENATOR
SKINNER ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
YOUR JOURNEY MEMBERS SHE IS.
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
I AM DOING AN ADJOURN IN MEMORY
FOR A BELOVED CAPITOL STAFFER
THAT MANY OF YOU MAY RECALL HE
WAS ALSO AN ADVOCATE AND A
TIRELESS CHAMPION FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE AND I'M
REFERRING TO PEAK PRICE. THE
PRICE DIED LAST FALL SEPTEMBER
TWENTY THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
DOING WHAT HE LOVED MOST WHICH
WAS. ARE RIDING HIS BICYCLE. HE
WAS BORN THE CAPE CANAVERAL TO
AN AIR FORCE FAMILY HIS FAMILY
LATER MOVED TO RIVERSIDE HE
STUDIED SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE
UC DAVIS AND THEN HE TOOK A JOB
HERE AT THE CAPITOL ANY ENDED
UP WORKING IN THE CAPITAL FOR
THIRTY YEARS. AND HE- WAS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSULTANT TO
SPEAKER WILLIE BROWN LATER TO
SPEAKER JOHN CARESS HE ALSO WAS
THE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS- PRIMARY
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS PERSON FOR
WASTE MANAGEMENT INCORPORATED.
AND ALSO STARTED HIS OWN
CONSULTING FIRM WHERE HE
REPRESENTED MANY ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS SO THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE A GOOD ADVOCATE IN
THE BUILDING. ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL- POLICIES. SINCE
TWO THOUSAND HE SERVED ON THE
BOARD OF THE COMMUNITY ALLIANCE
WITH FAMILY FARMERS ANY WORK TO
REFORM FOOD AND AG SYSTEMS AND
SUPPORT FAMILY FARMS. AND AS I
MENTIONED HE HAD A VERY LONG
INDUSTRIES CAREER AT WASTE
MANAGEMENT WHERE MY SCHEDULER
CHRIS WORKED WITH HIM. BOTH
CHRIS AND PETE WERE LOVERS OF
FOLK MUSIC AND CHRIS DESCRIBES
A VERY LOVELY STORY WHERE. ONE
DAY. PETE SURPRISED HER WITH
TICKETS TO A CONCERT TO
MUSICIAN THAT BOTH OF THEM WERE
PARTICULARLY FOND OF. AND CHRIS
WENT TO THAT CONCERT WITH
PIANIST WIFE AND DINNER
AFTERWARDS AND SHE WHEN SHE
TOLD ME ABOUT IT WHICH IT WAS
MANY MANY YEARS AGO. SHE
RECALLED THE EVENING AS IF IT
WERE YESTERDAY. IT REMAINED AT
ACTIVE IN HIS ADVOCACY EVEN IN
RETIREMENT. AND THROUGHOUT HIS
CAREER HE WAS A VALUED MENTOR
AND COUNSEL TO YOUNGER CAPITOL
STAFFERS WHO WENT ON TO BECOME
CHIEFS OF STAFF. STARTING THEIR
OWN CAN SOME OF THEM STARTING
YOUR OWN CONSULTING FIRMS. AND
SOME OF THEM BECOMING THE KEY
STAFF IN THE ENERGY COMMISSION.
HIS DAUGHTER JENNA PRICE NOTES
THAT HE CARED DEEPLY ABOUT
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO THINK
CRITICALLY AND TO LISTEN TO ALL
SIDES TO DEVELOP GOOD ADVICE
AND SOLUTIONS. THAT TOOK INTO
ACCOUNT DIVERSE VIEWS. HE'S
MISSED VERY DEARLY BY HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS INCLUDING
HIS WIFE SUSAN HIS DAUGHTERS
JENNA IN CHURCHILL AND HIS
GRANDCHILDREN. AND I ASK THAT
WE ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTERS SKINNER MR PRICE WAS A
VALUABLE PARTNER HERE IN THIS
CAPITAL ONE THROUGHOUT THIS
COMMUNITY HE WILL BE MISSED WE
BRING THE NAMES FOR TERRY CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED GO.
SOONER DOLLARS. SORRY MR
PRESIDENT I'D ALSO LIKE TO JUST
ADD ON AND- AND SAY- GOT TO
KNOW- JENNA. REALLY WELL- IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET P. AND I
JUST WANTED TO SAY MY
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY OF
REALLY THAT. GREAT GUY AND- AN
AWESOME FAMILY SO I JUST WANTED
TO ADD MY COMMENTS TO THAT AS
WELL. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SENATOR DALLAS.
CENTERS STERN. MISTER PRESIDENT
I AM I TO JUST WANT TO EXPRESS
MY APPRECIATION FOR PEACE
LIFETIME SERVICE- AND FOR A
LEGACY THAT. IT IS NOW QUITE
RICH HE WAS TAKEN TOO SOON FROM
US AND TO LOSE YOUR DAD. AT A
YOUNG AGE LIKE THAT- TAKES A
BIG PIECE OF YOUR HEART AND
YOUR SOUL BUT HE HE'S GOT SOME
GRANDCHILDREN OUT IN THE WORLD.
AND SOME AMAZING DAUGHTERS AND
I THINK THE WORK HE'S DONE AND
THE IMPRESSIONS LEFT ON THIS
CAPITAL ONE. WON'T LEAVE WITH
HIM SO- THANK YOU SENATOR FROM
BERKELEY FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND- MY CONDOLENCES
WELL TO THE FAMILY. THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN ANY ADDITIONAL.
COMMENTS ON MR APPROACH SEEING
NONE AGAIN IT WILL ADJOURN IN
MEMORY AND BRING HIS NAME FORTS
ARE CAN BE PROPERLY MORE ALLIES
NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I RISE THIS MORNING TO JERRY
MEMORY OF DORIS MARTIN OF
FULLERTON WHO PASSED AWAY ON
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR AT THE AGE OF NINETY. OF
COMPLICATIONS FROM COVERT
NINETEEN. DORIS CASEY BARTON
WAS BORN ON JULY TENTH NINETEEN
THIRTY IN OKLAHOMA CITY
OKLAHOMA. DORIS IS ONLY TEN
YEARS OLD WHEN HER FATHER
PASSED AWAY. AND SHE HER OLDER
BROTHER ROBERT INNER SISTER
DOROTHY ALL HAD TO WORK VERY
HARD TO HELP THE FAMILY THROUGH
THIS VERY DIFFICULT TIME.
DESPITE THOSE CHALLENGES DORIS
WAS AN HONOR STUDENT AND
STUDENT COUNCIL OFFICER IN HIGH
SCHOOL SHE THRIVED AS AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL THESPIAN
SOCIETY. DORIS ATTENDED THE
UNIVERSITY OF OKLAHOMA AND
EARNED A BACHELOR'S OF SCIENCE
IN EDUCATION SHE WAS A MEMBER
OF THE KAPPA DELTA PI HONOR
EDUCATION FRATERNITY AND THE
ALPHA GAMMA DELTA SORORITY WAS
THERE AT ALPHA. GAMMA DELTA
THAT YOU WOULD MEET THE LOVE OF
HER LIFE CLYDE BARTON JUNIOR AS
HE WAS WORKING HIS WAY THROUGH
COLLEGE BY BUSSING TABLES IN
THE HOUSE DINING ROOM. SLIDING
DOORS BARTON MERRY NINETEEN
FIFTY ONE AND WELCOME DEBORAH
THE FIRST OF THEIR THREE
CHILDREN THIRTEEN MONTHS LATER.
CLYDE'S CAREER AS A PETROLEUM
ENGINEER LET THE YOUNG FAMILY
TO MOVE OFF AND PUTTING DOWN
ROOTS LONG ENOUGH TO BEFRIEND
GOOD NEIGHBORS CONNECT TO THEIR
COMMUNITY AND BILL BONDS AND
MEMORIES THAT WOULD LAST THEM
FOR A LIFETIME. THE BARTON'S
TRAVELS TOOK THEM TO COLORADO
WYOMING TEXAS OREGON AND
EVENTUALLY HERE TO CALIFORNIA
WHERE THEY SETTLED IN ORANGE
COUNTY IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX.
WHILE LIVING IN WESTMINSTER
DORIS IN AN ECHO OF HER COLLEGE
DAYS AS A STUDENT LEADER CO
FOUNDED THE WESTMINSTER
FOUNTAIN VALLEY HUNTINGTON
BEACH CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY
WOMEN. IN REMAIN ACTIVE IN THE
ORGANIZATION FOR DECADES ALL
WHO HAD THE PLEASURE OF KNOWING
DOORS BARTON CAME TO ADMIRE HER
FOR HOW SHE APPROACH LIFE WITH
ZEST GRACE AND GOOD HUMOR SHE
WAS ESPECIALLY DEVOTED TO HER
CHILDREN. AND THEIR CHILDHOOD
DAYS WERE FILLED WITH WARMTH
AND LAUGHTER DOORS POSSESSED A
REMARKABLE SPIRITUAL STRENGTH
AND SHE THRIVES IN HER ROLE AS
A TEACHER A FAMILY LOVE AND
VALUES. DORIS LOVED HER
NEEDLEPOINT HOBBY BECOMING AN
ACCOMPLISHED ARTIST WITH THEIR
OWN PICTURE AND POLITICIZED SHE
ALSO LOVED. HER TRAVELS WITH
CLYDE THIS YEAR TO TRUE AROUND
THE WORLD. IN VISITED. MORE
THAN THIRTY COUNTRIES DORIS WAS
ALWAYS HAPPY TO RETURN HOME. TO
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. IN CLYDE
SIMPLE BUT BEAUTIFUL SUMMATION
OF HIS PARTNER OF SIXTY NINE
YEARS. DORIS WAS A SWEETHEART
DORIS MARTIN LEAVES BEHIND A
LOVING FAMILY. INCLUDING SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN THIRTEEN. GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN HER LOSS LEAVES A
HUGE VOID BUT HER LEGACY OF
CARE KINDNESS AND STRENGTH.
WILL LONG CARRY ON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE TURN
IN HER MEMORY THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN WILL
YOU BRING THE NAME FOR IT SO.
MISPERTON CAN BE PROPERLY MORE
ALLIES BY THE SENATE. AND WE
EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO LOS.
NEXT UP CENTER DORADO. I'M SURE
CENTER HERTZBERG. A REMARKABLE
RESEMBLANCE- MISTER. PRESIDENT
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE. THE
HIGHLY RESPECTED CULTURAL
ANTHROPOLOGIST MARGARET MEAD
ONCE SAID. NEVER DOUBT THAT A
SMALL GROUP OF THOUGHTFUL
COMMITTED INDIVIDUALS CAN
CHANGE THE WORLD INDEED IT IS
THE ONLY THING THAT EVER HAS.
LAST WEEK BASRA WE CAN GO ON
APRIL THIRTIETH. WE LOST ONE OF
THOSE THOUGHTFUL COMMITTEE
INDIVIDUALS AND THE WORLD WILL
FOREVER BE CHANGED. HE WAS AN
ACCOUNTANT WHO GRADUATED FROM
MICHIGAN STATE UNIVERSITY IN
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR. AND LIKE
SO MANY OF HIS POST WAR
GENERATIONS HE BOUGHT HIS
BROUGHT HIS DREAMS INTO THE
BRIGHT SUNLIGHT. AND WARM AIR
OF CALIFORNIA. THIS HUMBLE
ACCOUNTANT SOON BECAME WILDLY
SUCCESSFUL HOME BUILDER AND
FINANCIER. JUST AS HE HAD
FALLEN IN LOVE WITH HIS WIFE ET
A FEW YEARS BEFORE HE FELL IN
LOVE WITH HIS NEW HOME STATE.
OF CALIFORNIA. BUT REAL ESTATE
WASN'T JUST ABOUT MONEY FOR ELI.
HE WANTED ARE GOLDEN STATE TO
BE PLACE TO A PLACE WHERE
HOMEOWNERSHIP WAS ACHIEVABLE
PLACE A PIECE OF THE AMERICAN
DREAM ESPECIALLY FOR THE
GREATEST GENERATION WHO JUST
BOUGHT ONE THE PEACE FOR THE
WORLD. THE ACCOUNTANT TURNED
REAL ESTATE MOGUL WROTE A BOOK.
CALLED THE ART OF BEING
UNREASONABLE LESSONS IN
UNCONVENTIONAL THINKING. AND HE
WAS ON REASONABLE. HE WAS MY
FRIEND FOR NEARLY FORTY YEARS
ANY COULD DRIVE YOU CRAZY. BUT
HE DID SO WITH AN HONEST INTO
INTENTION OF MAKING ITS
COMMUNITY IS BELOVED STATE
BETTER HIS NAME. E. LIBRO. HE
WAS KNOWN FOR BUILDING IN
FUNDING EXTRAORDINARY MUSEUMS
FROM THE MUSEUM OF CONTEMPORARY
ART THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
MUSEUM OF ART IN THE MUSEUM
BEARING HIS NAME SAKE THE BROAD
MUSEUM AN INSTITUTION FREE TO
ALL. BUT IT SHOULD NOT MINDED
THIS WAS NOT CONFINED TO JUST
THE ART WORLD HE WAS WE
SUPPORTED SEVERAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. INCLUDING SANTA
MONICA COLLEGE WHERE HE COULD
FIND THE BROAD STAGE VENTURE
RUN BY DEAR FRIEND DALE
FRANSEN. AS WELL AS A LOS
ANGELES VALLEY COLLEGE WHERE HE
DONATED GENEROUSLY TO THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A LIBRARY THAT
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON TODAY.
HE I BELIEVED IN THE-
CONNECTION BETWEEN CULTURE IN
OUR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS. IN
SERVICE OF THIS PASSION HE AND
I WERE PARTNERS. IN HELPING THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT CREATE. A PERFORMING
ARTS HIGH SCHOOL IN DOWNTOWN
LOS ANGELES. THE LAST ELEVEN
YEARS WE SERVED TOGETHER AS
MEMBERS OF THE- THINK LONG
COMMITTEE OF THE BIGGER ONE
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
DEVOTING TIME AND ATTENTION TO
THE LONG TERM NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRUCTURAL
REFORM. EGGMAN FORMER GOVERNOR
DAVIS SOUGHT TO BUILD AN
ARCHITECTURALLY SIGNIFICANT
BUILDING IN THE IN FOR THE NEW
CALTRANS HEADQUARTERS IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES. HE CALLED
YOU I BROUGHT WHO SPEARHEADED
ARCHITECTURAL COMPETITION AND
WHEN THE WINNING DESIGN CAME UP
TWO MILLION DOLLARS OVER BUDGET
THE BROWN FOUNDATION COVERED
THE DIFFERENCE. THE PUSH FORMER
SPEAKER ANTONIO VILLARAIGOSA
AND I HARD FOR STATE SUPPORT OF
THE ICONIC WALT DISNEY. CONCERT
HALL. AT EVERY TURN EACH ONE OF
THESE PROJECT WHEN I TALK TO MY
FRIENDS IN THE LABOR COMMUNITY
HE LIE AT THE END OF EVERY
MEETING POINTED TO THE
CONTRACTORS AND THE PEOPLE IN
THE ROOM WHEN HE SAID. I WANT
TO ENSURE EVERY WORKER HIRED ON
THIS PROJECT GETS A FAIR WAGE
FROM THE FIRST TIME HE CAME TO
CALFORNIA THE LAST PROJECT YOU
WORKED ON. AND BEYOND THESE
ENDEAVORS ELI BRODE DEVOTED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
THE VISION FOR THRIVING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. AND CUTTING EDGE
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH. HE WAS ONE
OF HIS MOST ONE OF HIS MOST
GENEROUS SUPPORTERS OF LA'S
BEST. ONE OF THE CITY'S MOST
IMPACTFUL SCHOOL PROGRAMS
CONTRIBUTE OVER SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH.
AND CONTINUOUSLY FUND THE BROAD
INSTITUTE OF MIT OF MIT AND
HARVARD WHICH ADVANCES OUR
KNOWLEDGE OF THE GENOME AND
DEVELOPS GENETIC THERAPIES.
WHETHER OR NOT YOU AGREE WITH
THE LIBRO. HE UNDENIABLY
REPRESENTED THE SPIRIT OF A
GENERATION COMMITTED TO
IMPROVING THE WORLD. AND
INVESTING IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
OF OUR COMMUNITIES D. LAI.
BEING UNREASONABLE WAS TRULY AN
ART. ONE HE DERIVED FROM A
QUOTE BY GEORGE BERNARD SHAW.
REASONABLE PEOPLE ADAPT
THEMSELVES TO THE WORLD. EVEN
REASONABLE ONES HE SAID
PERSISTS IN TRYING TO ADAPT THE
WORLD TO THEMSELVES. THEREFORE
ALL PROGRESS DEPENDS ON THE
UNREASONABLE PERSON. THANK YOU
E. LIVE ROAD FOR YOU ON
REASONABLE NATURE. AND FOR
BEING ONE OF THE MOST
THOUGHTFUL COMMITTED. MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMUNITY I'VE EVER
KNOWN SURVIVED BY HIS
EXTRAORDINARY WIFE EDIE TWO
SONS. I WILL MISS YOU IN THE
STATE YOU LOVE. I ASKED AT THE
MET WILL BE JOINING THE MEMORY
MYSTERY LIBRO. THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG SOONER ALAN ON THE
GERMAN OF MR PEROT- MY
COLLEAGUE BURKE. FOR HIS
COMPREHENSIVE AND HEARTFELT
DISCUSSION OF ALL THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF MR BRODE TO
OUR BROADER LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY I HAVE TO SAY SOMEONE
WHO GREW UP IN IN LOS ANGELES
AS A KID I THE TRANSFORMATION
OF DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES AND IN
THE GRAND AVENUE IN PARTICULAR.
HI IS BEEN SO EXTRAORDINARY
WITH THE WITH THE EVERYTHING
FROM THE CONCERT HALL TO THE
PEROT MUSEUM THAT NOW YOU KNOW
LEAST BEFORE THE PANDEMIC HAVE
LINES AND LINES AROUND THE
BLOCK OF YOUNG PEOPLE FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS COMING IN FROM ALL
OVER THE CITY. YOU MIGHT
MIGRATE- FRIEND AND FORMER FOR
ABBAS SEVERAS LASKY OF COURSE
KNEW. MR BROUGHT SO WELL AS-
SAID THERE'S NO WAY YOU'LL EVER
BE SUCCESSFUL PUTTING A BIG
MUSEUM LIKE THIS A CUTTING EDGE
MUSEUM LIKE THIS IN DOWNTOWN
SHOULD BRING IT OVER THE WEST
SIDE OF COURSE. MISTER BRODY. I
THOUGHT NEW UNDERSTOOD THE
POTENTIAL DOWNTOWN THE
POTENTIAL OF THE VIBRANCY THE
COULD BE CREATED THERE ON GRAND
AVENUE. AND IT'S NOW AT
BENEFITING SO MANY PEOPLE AND
SO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE AND IT'S
ONE OF SO MANY THINGS THAT HE
DID. THAT THAT SHOWED VISION
THAT AND REASONABLENESS
BREAKING THROUGH THE OLD WAYS
OF THINKING. ABOUT THE CITY.
AND THAT JUST HE HE LEFT SUCH A
LEGACY LEFT SUCH A LEGACY AND
IT REALLY MADE THE LOOK OF THE
CITY TO FEEL THE CITY. SO MUCH
SO MUCH. SOCIAL CHANGE AND IT'S
INTERESTING IT'S IRONIC THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES TALK LITTLE ABOUT
THIS. HE PLAYED A ROLE OF
COURSE IN IN THE EXPANSION OF
THE CITY THE SPRAWL OF THE CITY
AND YET AND INVESTED SO MUCH.
IN THE COR IN THE HEART OF THE
CITY. I PERSONALLY BENEFITED
FROM MANY OF THESE OF THESE
INVESTMENTS BEING OF BE ABLE TO
VISIT HIS MUSEUM IN. THE BROAD
STAGE IN SANTA MONICA AND THE
DOT AND THE MULTI CONCERT HALL
AND ALL THE- THE INVESTMENT YOU
PUT INTO MOCHA AND LOCK MY- HE
ALSO AS WAS MENTIONED PUTS SO
MUCH INVESTMENT INTO. AND
EDUCATIONAL OUT OF ATTENTION OF
COURSE- PUT ON HIS ON HIS FOCUS
ON CHARTER SCHOOLS WHICH OF
COURSE WAS CERTAINLY AN
IMPORTANT PART OF HIS WORK BUT-
HE ALSO PUT A LOT OF MANY
TRADITIONAL. A PUBLIC SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN HIGHER EDUCATION
AS WELL. I CREATED A BROAD
PRICE FOR HIGH ACHIEVING URBAN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHICH IS AN
ANNUAL ONE MILLION- DOLLAR
PRIZE- THAT THEY WOULD GO OUT
TO. TO YOU KNOW TO JUST TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WERE IN
URBAN AREAS THAT WERE. THAT
WERE SURPASSING AND COMING UP
WITH NEW INNOVATIVE- INNOVATIVE
IDEAS YES OF COURSE HAD A
TRAINING ACADEMY FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICT EXECUTIVES. TRYING TO
HELP THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
INFRASTRUCTURES FUNCTION BETTER
TRYING TO GET THEM TRAINING AND
SUPPORT. AND IDEAS. HE ALSO WAS
VERY INVOLVED. WITH WITH
POLITICS HE ACTUALLY MANAGED
ALAN CRANSTON'S FIRST CAMPAIGN.
FOR THE U. S. SENATE BACK IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT AND THEN
LET IT. WAS WAS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE SUCCESSFUL CAMPAIGN
TO BRING THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL CONVENTION TO LOS
ANGELES. IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND- BY MENTION SEVERAL HE
SAID A NUMBER OF TIMES ON THE
ON THE RADIO THIS WEEK YOU KNOW
THE LA OF COURSE HAS A LOT OF
BILLIONAIRES. BUT THERE ARE SO
FEW WHO STEP UP IN THE WAY THAT
YOU AYE BRO DID- IF YOU IF ONLY
WE HAD MORE WHO WHO REALLY
STEPPED P. TO HELP INVEST IN
OUR CITY AND PUT ALL OF THEIR
THEIR TIME AND ENERGY AND
RESOURCES AND TREASURE. INTO
INTO DEVELOPING OUR CITY AND
BUILDING OUT THE HEART THE CORE
OF OUR DOWNTOWN. HE WILL BE
MISSED HE WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
VENTURE PHILANTHROPIST. AND I
JUST HOPE THAT THE NEXT
GENERATION OF PHILANTHROPIST
WILL STEP UP YOU KNOW WITH.
USING HIM ASA AS A INSPIRATION
TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
EDUCATION AND ARTS AND CULTURE.
AND MAKING OUR CITY A BETTER
PLACE. THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
ON THIS ITEM NOT SURE I AM SURE
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO BRIEFLY
MOVED TO BACK TO PRIVILEGE OF
THE FLOOR TENER DOG. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO-
RECOGNIZE THE BIRTHDAY OF
PERHAPS ONE OF THE BEST OR THE
BEST BASEBALL PLAYER THAT'S
EVER DONE THE UNIFORMS. IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL THAT
WOULD BE WILLIE MAYS. TODAY HE
TURNS NINETY ED- MISS PRESENT
PERMISSION TO READ PERMISSION
GRANTED. FROM UP PRESIDENT
OBAMA THIS MORNING BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE I GAVE LUÍT A
RIDE ON AIR FORCE ONE TO THE
ALL STAR GAME IN ST LOUIS. ALL
THE EVER FORGET THAT DAY
BECAUSE IT WAS ONE OF THE FEW
TIMES WHEN I WASN'T THE MOST
IMPORTANT PERSON ON THE PLANE.
EVERYONE WAS SO EXCITED TO SEE
WILLIE AND I WAS TOO I TOLD HIM
THAT IF HE HADN'T. IF IT HADN'T
BEEN FOR FOLKS LIKE HIM AND
JACKIE ROBINSON LEADING THE WAY
I BET YOU NEVER MADE IT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE. THE SPIRIT WILL BE
BROUGHT TO THE GAME AND THE WAY
HE CARRED HIMSELF NOT ONLY
CHANGE BASEBALL IT SEEMS
PEOPLE'S ATTITUDES AND HELP
YOUNG BLACK AND BROWN KIDS SEE
THEMSELVES DIFFERENTLY. WE ARE
LUCKY TO BE ABLE TO WALK THIS
EARTH WITH WILLIE MAYS AND I'M
GLAD THAT HE'S STILL GOING
STRONG. MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
AM DOING A RESOLUTION IN HONOR
OF HIS BIRTHDAY SO ANY MEMBERS
THAT WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON TO
THAT PLEASE LET ME KNOW. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
SENATOR JOE FOR THE- BIRTHDAY
TRIBUTE- MADAM SECRETARY LET'S
QUICKLY LOOK THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM SEVEN. DODD I HUESO. HER
TADO. MELENDEZ WILK. HIGHS
THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES- IF THERE'S NO FURTHER
BUSINESS CENTER I CAN SUGGEST
IS CLEAR THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
WHAT A FITTING END TO THE
SESSION AND TO OUR WEEK THANK
YOU TO THE SENATOR FROM NAPA.
FOR DOING THAT- TRIBUTE. THE
NEXT FULLER SESSION FOR US
COLLEAGUES WILL BE MONDAY MAY
TENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT TWO
PM THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY WHICH
TIME ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WILL RECONVENE ON MONDAY
AT TWO PM THANK YOU MEMBERS WE
STAND IN RECESS.